le petit bout donc j'ai fait on a fait
doubler en carton en épaisseur de jours
vous menez un peu à pas qui après vous
revenez en juillet êtes-vous revenu à
l'époque c'était morissette morissette
est née d'un petit oeuf tout petit petit
petit et mauricette a grandi et un jour
morissette elle a tellement grandi que
j'aurais fait cocorico
alors on a dit on va pas la prime aux
préceptes puisque là c'est notre
étonnement et on s'y attendait pas et
donc on a dit on va quand même pas tuer
morissette ont la garde et on a dit elle
est née ici restera là et on a diminué
le nom par maurice en fait ils chantent
plus il chante plus parce qu'on se pose
la question de pourquoi il a été dit
qu'il chantait en sans arrêt du matin
jusqu'au soir
en répétition et ce qu'il faut ça a été
prouvé que c'était faux
mes clients ils réclament juste la paix
la tranquillité c'est une résidence
secondaire ce sont des retraités ils
veulent pouvoir dormir dormir jusqu'à
normal le matin et il souhaiterait que
le coq en cause soit ne serait ce que
rend fermé pendant la nuit puisque à
priori c'est la lumière du jour qui
déclenche effectivement les chant du coq
c'est le propre du col de chanter le
matin mais mes clients sont sur place
depuis 2003 ou 2004 le coq est arrivé en
on est malgré tout et c'est tout le
contentieux tout dit ou le tout vivait
dans une zone urbanisée
moi mes clients ont une maison qui est
dans un lotissement on n'est pas la
campagne on vient eh bien ils ont fait
tout au long des quais